you and I have to actually have a child
custody agreement in place or the state
takes her essentially becomes the owner
of her oh seriously yeah it's stupid so
I got to this child custody thing I just
started getting creative about it
because it's like well what do I I I
just don't know what to do Cody Brown
admits he lied to Christine in order to
split custody of their youngest daughter
truly I don't trust her whether she's
going to be good to me or not is unknown
it's hard when you live it and then when
you get to see it and relive it again
it's very difficult emotionally so right
now while the episodes are airing it's
all very raw again things come to a head
on the Sister Wives as the two figure
out logistics following their split
including the sale of Christine's house
since she's moving to Utah with truly
and Cody he thinks he has a right to the
proceeds well it sort of deals with the
unknown I mean like you don't know
what else you'll be able to do
selling it now
you know would make it so you we could
pay off coyote pass and then Janelle
could actually build on it it'll be uh
four Lots four homes but the wives don't
disagree with this because they
recognize that my home would be either
the or the house that I built on my lot
would be either a guest house uh a house
that our children our adult children can
live in or visit in or even uh a rental
yeah and Christine not being part of the
plural marriage anymore she's not having
it if I'm going to sell my house
I'm going to keep the proceeds from
selling my house and put it towards the
next house that I purchase
so if I sell
I'm not going to put that money into
coyote pass I've been making every
payment on this house everyone
so no I
I won't be giving him any of the money
right now I'm requiring a bit of a
distance to be honest with you I feel
like I'm just starting to get to know me
I really like me and I want to keep it
that way and I also want to keep things
as easy emotionally since truly's around
me all the time too and when figuring
out where truly will stay when they
visit Arizona the topic of custody comes
up and Cody's making his own rules you
know you and I have to actually have a
child custody agreement in place or the
state takes her essentially becomes the
owner of her oh seriously yeah it's
stupid we're not legally married though
it just doesn't matter in this case
we've got an issue where we have to have
a child custody agreement in place and
that's a complete lie on Cody's end
which he's not afraid to admit to so I
got to this child custody thing I just
started getting creative about it and
Christine's like why do we need to do
this and I'm like well because the rule
book says you I don't know why we need
to do this and there is this thing in
the manosphere where it says if you're
getting divorced you're going to get
screwed bro meanwhile Christine just
finds the whole thing comical does he
not understand I want him to be around
his kids I'm not going to fight him on
that I've always wanted him to be around
his kids so why would I say I don't want
you to be around truly that doesn't make
any sense whatsoever he just doesn't
trust me that's what this comes down to
no I don't trust her how am I supposed
to trust her you know like what's what
net what's the next move she's going to
make against me in real time Christine
and truly made the move back to Utah
where she's living life as a single
woman everything is a lot more simple
than it used to be um which I didn't
even think think about but I'm single
now right so I kind of just decide what
I want to do and then do it the mom of
six told E.T last week she's never been
happier this new chapter of Christine
what does it look like
um I I just been having just more fun
and getting truly around her siblings
more around my mom more and my dad I've
just been able to hang out with family
my brothers and sisters uh yeah my
parents my kids more often than ever
before and I think it's complete
foreign